one of the nice things about being an
optimist is a pessimist is not going to
change my mind likewise being an
optimist probably won't change a
pessimist's mind I'm not inherently
against pessimism you know one of the
things I think is really funny about
pessimists is they all say I'm not a
pessimist I'm a realist well I'm a
realist too we're both talking about the
unknown future I believe that the
unknown future is more likely to be
bright pessimists believe the unknown
future is more likely to be dark the
thing that I think is great about
pessimists is they offer an alternative
point of view and they often cover off
my blind spots I like pessimists when
they're in the fight when they're going
to be with me shoulder to shoulder
fixing whatever we need to fix working
through whatever we need to work through
where pessimists are not helpful is when
they just lob grenades they stand on the
sidelines and point out all the problems
but they don't actually get involved in
rolling up their sleeves I'll take a
working pessimist over a sideline
pessimist any day